most of us are dealing with calorie
excess and exercise deprivation and
we're getting fat it's far better to
skip a meal than compromise it's far
better to learn you can go with two
meals a day maybe breakfast dinner as a
routine which I've adopted there's a
mindset doing this that I was not told
about I have the power to eat less and
feel good and achieve the goals wait or
otherwise I've completely changed my
mindset this was breakthrough for me
psychologically as well as
physiologically because I finally got
away from if food's there I won't eat it
because it's better to skip than to eat
in the culture we live in where there's
food everywhere all the time oh we've
just been taught that we're supposed to
eat three meals a day like I don't know
who came up with that look our bodies
are capable of so much more the single
most powerful activity you can do to
prolong your life is eat less every day
and then we can talk about what that is
but start out with that in your mind
shut your mouth your kitchen your
refrigerator and watch your health bloom